[Music]
you do an excellent first let me start
by saying congratulations movies
fantastic yeah I'm sure that's what
you're hearing from every person as
they're walking in the room no I mean
it's it's really a lot of people put
their hearts and souls into this film so
I'm thrilled yes
was this a role how did you stumble on
this role with it was it did you would
they offer to you did you go in for it
what happened I a Dexter Fletcher and
Matthew Vaughn Dexter's the director
Matthew's the producer reached out to me
and I read the script and talked with
Dexter and said yes within 24 hours and
six days later I was on camera oh wow
also there's some roles that you're like
you know you have months to prepare it
and there's others where it's like we
need you on set like yesterday yeah you
know yeah yeah no I've had a few of
those um and in a way it's terrific
because you I mean thankfully there was
enough time to have a lot of
conversations with people and people who
knew Sheila and know Elton and observe
the dynamic between them and so you know
there was there was the time for that of
course but it was kind of wild to just
sort of jump in and and it's almost like
you're you're being a part of a play
that you feel like people have been for
a really long time and you're like oh
okay what's the dance move alright this
year you know and and so it was so fully
formed by the time I was involved it was
just it's like I got to experience the
ride in a way while performing it that
that the audience does because you know
I would be seeing Tarun doing his thing
and the dancers and the lights and
everything and I'm like oh wow you know
and because I wasn't a part of those
true you know it
initial rehearsals so there was so much
discovery for me I would imagine yeah
then seeing the finished film for you
must have been a holy F moment totally
completely I mean like those
transitional sequences are just so
beautifully staged and choreographed and
in the story and how how the songs are
used and I mean it's just awesome I love
the movie I do as well before I run out
of time with you I have to ask you the
big question yes
how did you manage directing the
mandalorian so you make sure it's but
like this is like a Star Wars show yeah
you know you know what the the God's
honest truth is that I had I had
incredible support from Dave Filoni and
Jon Favreau and and the the process
Minoo the prep process and the shooting
and post and all of that it was so
incredibly collaborative and fun and
grounded and and so I just it was just
it was I wanted to just one follow-up
yeah what can you tease about your
episode if anything yes and can you talk
a little bit about the insane technology
they use yes okay so um I literally
don't even think I can tease anything
about this episode I don't think I can
say which episode it's yeah no I'm I'm
totally on lockdown but what I can say
about the technology it's it's really
Jon Favreau of course is is known for
pushing emerging technology forward and
what he did with with Jungle Book what
he's doing now with Lion King I mean
this is really extraordinary sort of
what what is possible because of because
of these projects and because of the way
I mean there were so many times when
when I would be like oh it's okay Jon we
can just we can just do it that way he's
like I just want to see if it's possible
like we just need to see if it's
possible and I'm like okay and then it's
tested
and way more times you know you find out
oh wow it is possible and it's better
you know and and so so yeah so that was
really exciting there's specifically
something that we shot in called that we
called the volume and and basically you
you step into it and you are you the
naked eye you can't tell that you are
surrounded by basically LED screens and
you feel like wherever you know the
story is taking place it's almost like a
this is the this is the wrong term to
use especially for this for this project
but it's almost like a holodeck
I gotta go they're gonna kill me I'm
just gonna say it cannot wait to watch
it and I can't wait and congrats on this
thank you